l'info en plus de cette chronique échos
de ce jeudi les chiffres du mondial de
l'automobile
et oui le mondial de l'auto qui a attiré
cette année un million deux cent trente
et un mille visiteurs c'est un petit peu
moins qu'en 2010 mais il reste le plus
fréquenté au monde un salon marquée par
les manifestations des salariés de
peugeot-citroën venus exprimer leur
colère suite aux plans annoncés de 8000
licenciement quelques maps pour conclure
la jambe à écho de la semaine alors tout
d'abord ce job dating le 23 octobre de
10h à 15h à l'espace 50 ans organisé par
pôle emploi et puis la semaine du
handicap à plaisir du 20 au 26 octobre
avec notamment une table ronde pour
l'emploi employeurs salariés créateurs
d'entreprise sont les bienvenus plus
d'informations auprès de la maison des
entreprises et de l'emploi de plaisir
mercialys prochain point sur l'économie
dans le 7-8 jeudi prochain mêmes
horaires on ouvre à présent une page
politique